viola started uh in 2011. the
inspiration behind starting viola was uh
at the time my 79 year old grandmother
she had
come to see me play while i was playing
for the denver nuggets you know one it
was just a blessing just to get her to
come get on a plane to come see me
because she was scared to death of
planes and i was excited to see her and
took her bags downstairs set her up and
she said for me to bring a bag back
upstairs so when i bought the bag back
upstairs as i bring it up i could hear
it shaking or whatever and it sounded
like it was like pills in it put it up
on the counter she comes up a couple
minutes later she zips it open and it's
like all kind of pills like a pharmacy
and i was like grandma why take so much
medication and she's like you know boy i
suffer from glaucoma diabetes all kind
of stuff she mentioned when she said
glaucoma um
i you know i was reading a newspaper in
colorado and reading about how cannabis
you know cure glaucoma patients i
started telling her about it and i was
like grandma you know you know cannabis
you know helps with glaucoma and it
could actually fix your eyes and the
whole thing and she finally asked she
said well what is cannabis i was like
it's marijuana weed she looked at me and
she said reefer she said boy you out of
your mind you think i'm about to smoke
some reefer she just started she laughed
for the like five minutes she couldn't
stop laughing she's like i cannot
believe you tried to get me to smoke
reefer and i was like now grandma's like
it's medicinal i was like it's different
here
she said boy i'm not smoking or rifa get
out of my face so the next day larry i
come on from shoot around and she's
sitting in the kitchen and she's
complaining about her eyes she's like my
eyes are killing me today i was like
well grandma why don't we just try
cannabis i was like you in a state where
it's legal i was like this would be our
secret i won't tell nobody
and she was just like
i'm in so much pain today i'll try
anything so i sent my boy to the
dispensary they recommend this train
called vietnam kush we bought a volcano
bag too because i didn't think she'd
probably want to smoke a blunt or
anything like that and i wasn't a smoker
at the time either and she started
smoking it and she's hitting it and
she's like blowing it out her nose
and i'm like looking at her and i'm like
grandma are you sure you don't smoke
weed and she's on laughing she's like
she smoked a cigarette one time and she
was 16 years old but she said to so she
hit it like three four times and then
the fourth time i looked at it her eyes
are getting a little glassy so i take it
out of the stairs put her in the room i
go upstairs and take my pre-game that i
go check on hundreds to make sure she's
okay not climbing the walls or something
crazy so i go and i knock on the door
and uh i don't hear anything so i'm
thinking she must have passed out so i
just look and i say grandma how you
feeling and she turned around and she's
crying tears she says i'm healed she's
like you know you know i haven't been
able to read the words of my bible in
over three years so she makes me start
so now we are both crying and i'm just
like grandma she's like everything is so
bright i can't believe like i can see
like god gave me my sight back you know
i had been reading these articles how
cannabis was medicine but like
for it to help her and like
clear her eyesight up that she'd go
downstairs and read her bible it just
changed my
just
everything for me about cannabis at that
moment and that's when i just started to
read and learn more about it when we had
to go get our first uh license which was
two years later you know we decided to
name the company after the person that
inspired us to get there which is my
grandma viola so that's how we got the
name of the company
and you know we've been moving ever
since
you